oui vraiment on entend de plus en plus
les enfants nos amis on a lu l'usp et
c'est clair qu'on aura marqué une montée
des coups incroyables mais monsieur
parce que c'est un peu notre relâchement
nous en tant que citoyens faux site du
gouvernement sommes nous déjà un sixième
vague le verdict vient de tomber québec
c'est bien le cas et chez les experts on
constate une chose le train de la coved
est encore une fois en marche l'ensemble
des indicateurs qui était suivi pour
déterminer si on était dans une nouvelle
vague tous ces indicateurs pointent dans
la direction d'une sixième bague même en
l'absence de données complète depuis
janvier plusieurs indicateurs tourne
maintenant au rouge le nombre de cas
confirmés par test pcr a triplé depuis
une semaine et le nombre de tests
rapides auto-déclaré a presque doublé
ils ce sont des chiffres probablement
largement sous-estimé les six national
d'excellence prévaut également qu'au
rythme actuel des infections ou pourrait
s'attendre à 200 hospitalisations par
jour d'ici la mi-avril il faudrait que
le nouveau souvient ba2 se reproduit une
vitesse vertigineuse il est presque 50%
plus contagieux que son cousin au micron
et produirait une charge virale deux
fois plus importante selon une étude
récente une personne qui attrape ce
barrière la contamine de 10 à 12
personnes dans son entourage c'est c'est
un taux de reproduction qui est énorme
et qui s'approche dessus la rougeole qui
est une des maladies les plus
contagieuses pour l'instant d'un milieu
de la restauration les dégâts sont
limités avec peu d'établissements fermés
même constat dans cette manufacturier
qui a tiré des leçons de deux ans
pandémie america préoccupation est là
elle est là parce qu'on était vraiment
quand même très affecté et au cours des
deux dernières années par un taux
d'abstention élevé car j'en étais malade
alors on
évaluera pas trop rapidement mais tant
qu'on a une sixième vague là depuis dix
ans des infections pourraient tester la
santé publique à réviser ses positions
ça me surprendrait pas qu'on s'enligne
pour une prolongation de
de cette obligation de porter les
masques dans certains contextes parce
que je pense pour que d'ici le 15 avril
le problème du micron doit être réglo de
ba2 pour être élu depuis une semaine on
a observé une hausse de 16 % des
hospitalisations au québec ici normand
grondin radio canada montréal